>>Male Presenter: Thanks for coming, everyone.
OK.
Robert de Sorbon, James Pierpont, John Harvard,
Patrick Awuah.
One of these is not like the others.
Three of these men founded universities destined
to change the face of education on a continent.
John Harvard just gave a bunch of books and
got a school named after it.
Of the remaining three, we're very lucky to
have the only one who's in a position to actually
tell us what he did, why he did, and how he
did it.
In 1989, I think it was, Paul Maritz is very
fond of telling the story of how he met Patrick
back when they were both at Microsoft.
And Paul Maritz is now the CEO of VMware,
Chairman of the Board for the Grameen Foundation.
As Paul tells this, he says he met this kid
who confided in him that he didn't want to
spend his entire career at Microsoft.
He wanted to go back to his home country and
found a university.
And Paul said, "Well, good luck with that."
[clears throat] And thought to himself, "Well,
you know.
Everyone needs dreams."
And it was eight or nine years later.
Patrick left Microsoft to go to the Haas School
in Berkeley, where he developed a business
plan for creating a self-sustaining liberal
arts university in Ghana.
I think it was four years later, Ashesi admitted
its first students.
It's now ten years after that and the tenth
anniversary of Ashesi, Ashesi students are
already changing the face of education in
Africa.
Ashesi students are in basically impossible
demand.
They're recognized for their ethics and their
critical thinking skills as the future leaders
of government and of industry.
And the large schools, the private and the
public universities in Ghana, are actually
getting pressured.
They're being told they need to change a little
bit, become a little bit more like Ashesi.
So, the name Ashesi comes from the Akan word
for "beginnings."
And was inspired by the quotation from Goethe,
which is, "If there is anything you can do,
or dream you can, begin it.
Boldness has genius, power, and magic.
Begin it now."
So, today I'm honored to have with us and
to introduce somebody who embodies both the
boldness, the genius, the power, and the magic
of beginning something.
And I'm pleased to introduce Patrick Awuah,
who began it all.
[applause]
>>Patrick Awuah: Thank you very much, Pablo.
So, what I thought I'd do this afternoon is
just tell you the story of Ashesi--of why
it's here, of what it is today, and what it
is going to become in the future as we plan
the future of this institution.
So, Ashesi, as you can see on the slides--on
this first slide--is really about a new Africa.
And so, when I left Microsoft to start on
the journey to build this university, I wasn't
actually thinking about just the fact of building
a university.
What I was really concerned about was contributing
to what's a renaissance on a continent.
And what I was thinking about was the future
happiness of an entire people.
This is what I set out to do.
And the question is, why start a university?
So, imagine that you are just a guy or a gal
at Google or Microsoft.
And you wanna change the future of a continent.
And you don't have the financial resources
personally of Bill or Larry [laughs] or people
like that.
But you want to change a continent.
What do you do?
Where do you begin?
For me, it was trying to figure out, is there
some catalytic thing that I could do that
would, in the long run, very long-term, achieve
the result that I wanted, that I sought.
And I did a simple exercise at some point
with friends and family in Ghana, where we
would look at different problems.
Any problem.
Health care, infrastructure, governance, education,
you name it.
And ask, "Why is this the way it is?"
And we would get a set of answers for each
of those problems.
But then, take each of those answers and ask,
"Why?"
And try to drill down to figure out is there
something that seems to be fundamental across
all these problems.
And as we did this exercise, one thing stood
out.
And that thing was leadership.
Leadership is defined by all the people in
positions of influence--the decision-makers--and
what they were doing, whether it was making
the wrong decisions or just accepting the
status quo as it was, or even being corrupt.
And so, and this is a very strong signal,
right?
So, I started to ask the question about--
[phone rings]
about how leaders are created.
And that took me to take a second look at
education, from primary school through graduate
school.
And what I found was--and again, higher ed
made a big signal for a couple of reasons.
One is, I visited university campuses where
the classes were huge.
You would see hundreds of students, even over
a thousand students, in a classroom, with
one professor.
And the classroom was physically not big enough.
So, students would be standing outside on
the verandas looking through windows for lectures.
I spoke with some of my own colleagues who
studied computing in college.
And whose education in computer science involved
writing code on paper, not actually running
anything through a compiler or testing code,
and getting graded on paper.
And so, this was one thing I saw.
It was very troubling.
The second thing was data that was telling
me that only, at the time, about two percent--and
it's still about five percent today--but back
then, about two percent of college age kids,
18 to say 24- year olds, were in college in
Ghana.
And the problem with two to five percent is
it's too small, but also, by definition, the
people in college across sub-Saharan Africa
will run their countries one day.
By definition.
If you're in college, if you're among the
two percent, or today the five percent, you
will be the ones who--.
They would be the ones running the courts,
running the schools, setting health policy,
building infrastructure, etc.
So now, for an individual thinking of what
to do with limited resources, it seemed like,
OK.
If I could address this two percent problem,
this five percent problem, I could achieve
catalytic impact long-term.
Because if I could change the way these leaders
are educated, then there would be a sea change
in Ghana.
And if we could do it across sub-Saharan Africa,
imagine a continent transformed.
So, this is how I got to decide what to do,
to think of developing ethical leaders who
have the ability to innovate, to be creative,
to not accept the status quo as it is.
And so, I quit Microsoft and I got scared.
So, every, it seemed every other day or so
I would wake up and wonder, "What am I doing?"
And then, I saw these words.
So, I typed them up and I put them on my mirror.
And I'd read them every day.
Every day.
So, the day I decided, I realized actually,
that I was committed, I said, "Wow.
This is the beginning."
And that's why Ashesi is called what it's
called--the beginning.
So, we've come a long way in ten years.
This is a picture of our campus, our permanent
campus, when it was under construction.
We have 500 students.
We started with 30 in 2002.
We've deployed world-class technology.
So, kids who study computer science not only
design code, but they actually run code and
have a real experience.
We have 370 graduates.
A hundred percent job placement within six
months of our graduating classes.
A beautiful campus.
And increasing global recognition.
So, this is an amazing thing to be a part
of.
But you know what amazing is, right?
Google is amazing.
And at the heart of it is liberal arts core
curriculum.
When I came to the United States for undergraduate
education at Swarthmore, I experienced an
education unlike anything I had seen up until
that time.
Professors who wanted me to think.
Professors wanted me to tell them what I thought,
who wanted me to be analytical, both in a
qualitative and a quantitative way.
And who wanted me to have a breadth of vision.
And they demanded this of all the students
who went there.
And so, an education that was the exact opposite
of the rote learning that I'd been through
up until that point.
And so, we've implemented that at Ashesi--this
mix of the liberal arts with computer science,
business administration, and MIS.
That's what we've done in our first ten years.
And the results are staggering.
This is data from a study that was done by
a team of MBA students from Berkeley.
They came to Ghana and they went around corporate
Ghana asking, "How would you rank university
graduates in this country?"
And Ashesi stands out.
And we think that it's really because of our
incredible focus on the liberal arts core,
our focus on teaching people, young people,
to have integrity and to care about what they
do and about their impact wherever they are.
Ninety-five percent of our graduates stay
in Africa.
I said, as I told you, they all get jobs.
Most of them are in Africa, which is great.
The five percent that are not in Africa, are
typically pursuing graduate education in the
United Kingdom or the United States.
So, we proved our educational model.
And we built a permanent campus.
The question is, where do we go from here?
[pause]
We're going to continue to do all the things
that we're doing--classrooms that encourage
conversation and discussion, interaction between
students and faculty and students interacting
with each other in debating with each other.
Spaces that inspire people, that invite people
to gather and to really ask this question,
"What is the good society?
What should it look like on this continent?
And how do we achieve it?
What is our role in achieving it?"
[pause]
We have a requirement for community service
at Ashesi.
So, it's this balance between saying we really
want ethics and civic engagement to be central
to what we do, but it's something we can't
force.
So, we say, "Well, you've gotta do it before
you graduate."
But we set just a small amount of hours required
and hope that students will do more.
And they all do more.
In 2008, an amazing event occurred on campus,
where a student body in Ghana decided to adopt
a student-run honor system and to come to
the faculty and say, "We will not cheat on
exams.
We will not tolerate those who do."
And the reason, ultimately, they decided to
do this is because, if you think about it,
cheating in exams in a classroom is what corruption
looks like when you're 20 years old.
And if you have an institution that tolerates
that, you're building, or you're nurturing
future corrupt leaders.
If you have an institution that does not tolerate
that, then you're developing future leaders
that you can trust with a central bank, who
you can trust with the lives of people and
infrastructure that those people will live
and work in.
And so, this is an amazing event.
We stepped out of the classrooms for exams.
We don't proctor exams.
And students hold themselves to this rule.
Now, of course unfortunately, we always have
a few students who do try to cheat in exams.
And fortunately, their peers hold them accountable.
They're brought before a judicial committee
that includes students.
And they are held accountable.
And to see this happening and the interest
that it has generated, not only within our
campus, but outside our campus as the accreditation
board has initially been very skeptical about
it, as corporate leaders have spoken out in
favor of it, as high school students are so
fascinated by this thing, that when we go
talk with them about Ashesi, this is a thing
they most want to talk about--about this society,
this community that has decided that it will
no longer tolerate corruption among its ranks.
[pause]
So, what next?
We call it "Vision 20-20."
And I'll run quickly through it.
And again, the process for getting to what
we do, what we're going to do.
As we set about thinking about the next ten
years of Ashesi, we asked ourselves, "There's
so many things that we could be doing.
How do we decide which ones to do and which
ones to not do and which ones to postpone?"
Right?
And we decided, "Well, let's go back to our
mission statement."
And our mission statement is to educate a
new generation of ethical, entrepreneurial
leaders in Africa.
Africa.
And we asked, "For what?"
The answer is what I started with--to drive
a renaissance on the continent, to change
a continent for the next generation.
And in order to do that, we realized we needed
to be educating people for industry and for
government.
And so, we set about starting from where we
are today, figuring out what are the things
that we need to do to educate leaders for
industry and government.
And we have three broad areas that we're going
to address.
First of all, we're going to strengthen our
base, which is the people in our community.
We're going to focus on diversity in excellence.
Our mission statement talks about Africa.
Not Ghana.
Africa.
So, this will become a more pan-African institution.
We will grow from a current ten percent of
our student body being from outside Ghana
to between 30 and 50 percent being from outside
Ghana in the next ten years.
We will maintain gender balance.
We have achieved it.
We have approximately 50 percent of our students
are women.
We will provide more scholarships so that
we continue to increase economic diversity
within our ranks.
[pause]
We will create facilities to strengthen campus
culture.
So, more housing so that more people from
diverse backgrounds live and learn together.
You look at a place like Ghana.
It's a country the size of the state of Oregon.
There are over 50 different languages spoken
there.
They're Christians and Muslims and many other
religions in this country.
If you look at Africa, the diversity is even
greater.
And it is very important that these young
people live and learn together.
Because we have committed to that, and because
we have committed to engaging in a conversation,
in 2006, Ashesi students elected a woman as
Head of Student Government for the first time
in Ghana's history.
And within two years after that, three other
universities have done the same thing.
This is a sea change that we talk about--setting
an example that changes an entire country
and what it believes to be possible.
We're going to develop a fund specifically
to attract and hire Africans in the diaspora
to return home.
We found that there are many people who want
to come back home, who have student loans
they have to pay off, and therefore, need
to be on a US salary scale in order to do
that.
But if we can have funding to just take care
of those loans, then they can return home
and be on a local salary scale and make their
contribution to their continent.
So, this is going to be another thing that
we focus on.
The next thing is to broaden our impact.
Now, for this, we've decided on three areas
that we're going to tackle.
The first is engineering and applied sciences.
Computer science and MIS, we're already doing,
fit into that.
But we're going to get into electrical engineering,
computer engineering, mechanical engineering.
And we took the time to go talk with companies
in telecommunications, in the oil and gas
industry, and also in light manufacturing
to guide what we do.
And so, these are the majors that we're going
to do next.
These will be leaders for industry.
But actually, the systems design mind will
be incredibly helpful in government as well.
And the engineering program will have not
only strengths in systems and design thinking,
but also in entrepreneurial thinking.
The second area is management and economics.
So, to add economics to the business degree
and to learn from the examples of Latin America,
where a few countries developed such strong
undergraduate programs in economics, that
their top graduates came to the United States
for their PhD's through the best PhD programs
here.
They've returned to their countries.
They're running central banks, ministries
of finance.
They're presidents and they've changed their
continent.
And we think that we can replicate this in
Africa.
And finally, law and society.
So, economics and management is leaders for
industry and government policy.
Law and society, leadership for government
for civic society.
It turns out that a lot of kids in high school
who have an ambition to enter government,
look to political science and law as the path
to get there.
And so, we're going to meet that need.
It is also the case that those countries that
have strong rule of law are the ones that
do the best economically and socially in terms
of human rights, civil rights and so on.
And of course, all of this will be based on
a liberal arts core, which is central to everything
that we do.
Engineering is the first thing that we're
going to engage and we're basically designing
the curriculum and the buildings, the labs,
and so on.
I would like to invite you to join our community.
Follow news from Ashesi.
Invest in Africa's future.
And by the way, I think Google is doing an
amazing job of investing in Africa's future.
And I see lots of companies that look at that
map that you have of a continent that is dark
and say, "Oh, there's nothing there."
And I talk to Googlers and what I hear is,
"Oh, it's not lit up.
Let's go light it up."
I mean, that's, that's fantastic.
And I invite you to continue to do that.
Visit us.
I think that this is one of the most compelling
projects in Africa.
And your visit is actually super important
for our students.
What do I mean by that?
In any organization, in any society, in any
country, there is an understood performance
horizon that people see.
People have a performance horizon.
And it is really important when somebody within
that community pushes the envelope, pushes
that horizon a little higher and demonstrates
to others that actually, our performance horizon
can be higher than it currently is.
And I have found that when our students engage
with people like you all, who have an incredibly
high performance horizon, it helps reset what
they aim for in the future.
And that's why I'm inviting you to visit.
Be part of the solution.
Come guest lecture.
It could be a day.
It could be a week.
It could be a whole semester--everything in-between.
Service technical advisers to help us with
our own IT systems on-campus.
Or, to assist a students who's working on
a project for his or her senior design project.
These are all super important.
And finally, please be an online advocate
for Ashesi.
Help spread the word.
I think that it is very important in this
world that when something good is happening
in a corner, that we shine a light on it so
others can see and follow.
And so, come join us.
We'd really appreciate it.
Thank you.
[applause]
>>Male Presenter: So, we've got plenty of
time for questions and discussions, but because
we're taping, I'm asked that either you go
to the microphone there or that I hand you
one of these microphones.
Brave individuals.
>>Male #1: How did the other universities
react when you set up Ashesi?
>>Patrick Awuah: Well, when we first started,
I think there was a lot of skepticism on different
fronts.
I mean, first of all, I was 35 years old and
I was gonna start a university.
And just to give you some context, a 35-year
old in Ghana is considered a small boy.
And so, there were people, quote unquote.
So, there were people who were just skeptical
because a young person was going to do this
and didn't believe it could happen.
There were people who, the liberal arts approach
is so different.
The idea that a student applies for college
and is required to take a breadth of subjects
before they specialize was new.
And so, there was some skepticism about that.
But ultimately, we were allowed to proceed.
And I think that there is, today, very widespread
acknowledgment that the Ashesi experiment
is delivering really good results.
And so, people are starting to take a much
closer look at what we're doing and thinking
through how they might replicate it as well.
[pause]
>>Female #1: I'm sorry.
Hi, my name is Nikki.
And I have a question that has to do, I guess,
with corruption.
Last January or so, I was at Ashesi before
you made the new campus.
>>Patrick Awuah: OK.
>>Female #1: And I was listening to a presentation
by the founders of DreamOval.
And they're talking about all the great projects
they've done with the Grameen Foundation,
with nursing in the Northern Region as well
as all the different solutions that they created.
But one of the issues that they brought to
light was that even though they have great
products and they're able to execute well
on it, there's always this cultural notion
of bribes, especially when you're trying to
secure certain government contracts.
>>Patrick Awuah: Right.
>>Female #1: And different things.
And I know one of my friends recently moved
back to start a company in Ghana and talked
about the issues of giving bribes to get off
the ground.
And it seems like that's a larger cultural
problem that even with great leadership, you
have to have that across the board.
And have you thought about that?
Or, how are ways that you're looking at that
in the community?
>>Patrick Awuah: Right.
OK.
So, that's a good question.
I mean, we're in an environment where, particularly
when you're dealing with government offices,
there's this endemic culture of people asking
for bribes in order to let you do what you're
doing or for them to do their jobs.
My response to that has been fairly simple.
We just don't do it.
And the thing is, what I found is that when
it really comes down to it, you can get things
done without paying bribes.
You might be slowed down a little bit, but
when it becomes very clear to people that
this is not going to happen, then they let
you get on with it.
OK?
And for me, I think, you all know about bucket
lists, right?
There's a set of things that you wanna do
before you kick the bucket.
Well, it's actually important to also have
an anti-bucket list, right?
The set of things that you're not going to
do before you kick the bucket.
[laughter]
And this is one of those things that's in
my anti-bucket list.
So, my view of it is first of all, if you
do it, then things get really messy because
then they've got you.
And they'll never let you go.
And if you don't do it, it pushes you to,
first of all, work with those organizations
and those institutions that don't do it, which
is a much healthier way to be anyway.
And apart from that, I think that you eventually
will get things done and you'll get--.
My experience has been the people who have
put pressure on me for this, I think after
the fact, respect me more for the stand that
we've taken at Ashesi.
And this is what I encourage everybody to
do.
[pause]
>>Male Presenter: As the organizer of the
talk, I get to ask some questions, too.
Which is, so, at Google we're a technology
company.
And when your only tool is a hammer, everything
looks like a nail.
So, looking at this, the first thing that's
spinning through my head is, "How can we throw
technology at the solution?
How can technology be thrown at the question
of educating ethical, socially aware, liberal
arts students?"
I'm sure you've thought a bit about that.
Could we get you to spend a couple of minutes
hypothesizing how technology could help you
go one or two more steps along?
>>Patrick Awuah: OK.
So, first of all, let me just say that technology
has already played a role in the work that
we're doing.
And I'll tell you different kinds of technology
and the roles they played.
So, when Ghana first set off on this path
for democracy, mobile phones and FM radio
turned out to be extremely important for making
sure that our elections were fair because
people had mobile phones at the polling stations
and they could call in and report if something
was going wrong.
Technology is being deployed in Ghana today
with the voter registration to do biometric
registration for voters.
So now, it's really difficult for people to
do multiple registrations.
And when they do, they get caught.
So, technology can play a role to the extent
that it enables things to be more transparent
and hold people accountable.
OK?
In terms of the particular role of how do
you educate people to have integrity, that's
a more difficult question because I feel that,
for Ashesi anyway, it has required high touch.
It has required many, many conversations in
classrooms, outside the classroom, about the
age-old question of what the good society
should be in our country.
And you need to do that.
But I also, two years ago, the accreditation
board asked us to stop the honor system.
It wasn't so much, they were concerned about
the idea that students say they're gonna be
honest, but they didn't believe that if we
weren't proctoring exams assumes we're not
in fact cheating, OK?
And so they asked us to stop it.
And this resulted in a big--.
I got copied on hundreds of letters that our
students wrote to the accreditation board.
And I read every letter.
It was--.
And we all, this thing hit the news.
I was on television.
Students were on radio and television, talking
about it.
So, this was technology broadcasting an event
that was happening in this small school in
Accra.
And then, of course, there was just this huge
conversation that took off on Twitter and
Facebook with students from other universities
questioning our students about whether this
was real or not.
So again, technology was a platform where
the intimate conversation that we had had
on campus was now getting out into the broader
community.
And I know that there's students.
We did an ethics conference and there were
students from other universities that came.
There were some students from the University
of Ghana that came to Ashesi and asked to
have lunch with me to talk about this.
And they heard about it because technology
helped broadcast it.
So, I think, I see technology as a basic infrastructure
that helps us get the word out.
And over time, will facilitate a conversation,
a two-way conversation as well.
[pause]
>>Female #1: Hi.
Sorry.
I had another question.
>>Patrick Awuah: OK, sure.
>>Female #1: [laughs] Another thing I noticed
when I was back in Ghana at Ashesi, was that
the founders of DreamOval as well as other
entrepreneurs had really great ideas and really
innovative products, but getting VC funding,
internally in Ghana, or getting the resources
was, seemed very difficult, either one, because
they were too young, so they thought maybe
it was some scam or two, just because it wasn't
as readily available.
And so, how does one look at, I guess, the
issue of bringing the resources and the talent
together in Ghana versus, I guess, places
like Silicon Valley, where it's just readily
available?
>>Patrick Awuah: Right.
So, that's a very good question.
Silicon Valley is an amazing place.
And venture capital has been an incredible
factor in driving what is happening here.
We don't have that in Ghana yet.
But I am pretty optimistic that as we see
more clearly what's happening in the rest
of the world, there is a possibility for this
to also come to Ghana.
I think that it's been, it's very important
that DreamOval is essentially pushing the
envelope, right?
This performance horizon that I talked about.
And if you came to Ghana 20 years ago, you
wouldn't see a bunch of young people, which,
as big an ambition as those guys have, right?
To have a 24-year old, a group of 24-year
olds say, "We are going to implement mobile
money and we're going to change the world
for all these poor people who are unbanked,"
is not something that you would have seen,
but you see that today, because of the work
that we're doing in Ashesi.
And I think that as we see more of those kinds
of attempts that that also will attract capital
to support people like that.
I really hope that we can have more of an
incubation culture in Ghana and on the African
continent.
I mean, there are other institutions that
are beginning to do this.
There's an organization called Meltwater that
is doing this is Ghana.
And I hope that we'll see more of that in
the years to come.
[pause]
>>Male #2: Hi.
So, what do I want to say?
Yeah.
You were talking about bringing, expanding
the offering for things like electrical engineering.
>>Patrick Awuah: Right.
>>Male #2: And there are now online courses
like those from MITx--
>>Patrick Awuah: Right.
>>Male #2: which are making a follow into
this.
Can you make use of this?
Would it help what you are doing?
>>Patrick Awuah: Yeah.
I mean, our faculty look at MIT OpenCourseWare
quite a bit.
We have a relationship with those guys where
we actually even get a local copy of it.
So, they take snapshots.
So, we actually have locally hosted OpenCourseWare
on campus.
And I can tell you that as we're designing
the electrical engineering program, that's
one of the sources that we've looked at to
guide us.
[pause]
>>Male #3: Hi.
With only a few percent of the people who
are of a suitable age to go to college, going
to college, I can see how a step in the quality
of education and the ethics of education can
make a real contribution to society.
But in places like the US where lots of people
go to college and ethics is on the decline,
what strategy can we adopt?
[laughter]
>>Patrick Awuah: OK.
So, look.
I think that the United States and other advanced
countries need to never forget the basics.
OK?
I think that there's some classical ideas
that sometimes, as we pursue technology and
advancement, we start to think that Plato's
"Republic," or "The Allegory of the Cave"
and things like this no longer apply.
But there's some ideas that really are timeless.
And I think that it's very important that
all institutions of learning pay attention
to the idea that ethics is important and that
civic engagement is important.
I would also like to say that there is a dark
side in the world.
And those guys, they have no qualms about
indoctrinating people with bad ideas.
OK?
And the way to counter that is to make sure
that we are lighting up people's minds with
the basic things, those timeless ideas.
Venture capital, this whole model of financing
young people and having patient capital and
putting money into a company without a lot
of collateral or any collateral, that wouldn't
work if there was no trust.
You need a high-trust environment for this
whole phenomenon to be successful, right?
So that's my view of it.
[pause]
Hi, Brigitte.
>>Female #3: How are you?
>>Patrick Awuah: Good.
>>Female #3: I have a few questions.
One, given the kind of environment in Ghana
in terms of employment, you mentioned that
100 percent of the students get employment.
Curious about where that is?
I know that a lot of the traditional companies,
the tel-cos and the banks, tend to dominate.
And in that environment, two things.
Do you think that they're able to make change?
Like, do you think that they are having an
impact outside of themselves?
Only because the hierarchical nature of the
environment basically says you're small, you
be quiet, this is how we operate.
The other side is compensation.
So, I know compensation varies incredibly
drastically in Ghana.
>>Patrick Awuah: Right.
>>Female #3: So, understanding, do you see
your students being rewarded more on the compensation
side?
'Cause I think that's gonna be a big factor
in keeping them local in the long term and
not going to Nigeria.
[laughs]
>>Patrick Awuah: Right.
So, those are very good questions.
So, we see our students actually climbing
up the corporate ladder wherever they go quite
quickly.
And I assume that increased compensation goes
with that.
So, I think that resolves itself.
I talk with chief executives in the country
who have now decided that Ashesi is going
to be a key place to hire from, particularly
because they're engaged with succession planning.
And they're looking for people that they think
can rise up into middle management and eventually,
into executive management.
And they think Ashesi is a place that they
can get those kinds of people.
So, that's encouraging.
Those are very encouraging conversations for
me to have.
Your other question had to do with jobs, right?
And again, I think it comes down to the basics.
If somebody is well-educated and is a problem-solver
and has an entrepreneurial mind, and you put
that person even in a corporate structure,
they will come up with new ideas, new ways
for the organization to grow.
And so, for example, when an Ashesi alum goes
and works in a bank and goes to their manager
and says, "There's this whole population of
people who are unbanked.
And we need to be thinking of a strategy to
reach those guys."
And managers convince management to pursue
that.
Now, that bank is growing, right?
It's now expanding to look at a segment, a
market segment, that they hadn't before just
because of this one person who had the idea.
And as it enters in that segment, they'll
be jobs that come with that.
Recently, GE entered Ghana and they hired
from Ashesi to open up their Accra office.
And now, the company is working multimillion
dollar deals in the country.
And that's going to generate more jobs in
Ghana.
And so, when I started this project, I said
to myself, "This is a long-term play.
It's gonna take a couple of decades or maybe
three decades for me to see the full impact
of the work that we're doing."
In the meantime, just paying attention to
what are the steps that we're taking and what
are the little glimmers that we're on the
right path?
And I think that it's, so far it looks promising.
[pause]
>>Male #4: Hello.
I'm interested in knowing more about your
students.
What are the criteria to get into Ashesi?
And what barriers do they face during their
education that might prevent them from graduating
and being successful in a college?
And what, how does the college help them achieve
that success?
>>Patrick Awuah: OK.
So, Ashesi student body is very diverse.
So, we have students from poor, rural villages
or even urban slums.
We have students from quite affluent families
and everything in-between.
So, it's very dispersed.
Now, their academic background, as you might
imagine, is different, right?
So, the kid who grew up in a rural village
went to an under-resourced school, maybe went
to a school and didn't even have a math teacher.
It's at a disadvantage.
When we make admissions decisions, what we
do is we look at a standardized national exam
and the accreditation board has minimum standards
for admission.
We certainly will not go below those standards.
But more importantly, we look at the person.
So, we do interviews.
Students write essays.
We try to really understand who this person
is.
And the idea is, the kid who's self-taught
and got a "C" in math is often just as bright
as a kid who went to a really good school
and got an "A" in math.
They just didn't have the resources.
And we need to give that person an opportunity.
And we need to provide the resources to help
that person.
So, for example, having a learning lab where
they can go and get extra help with math and
English and things like that.
Those things are very important to help people
get through.
Now, once they're--.
So, that's part of the answer to the second
part of your question.
One of the things that prevent people from
being successful in college, interestingly,
some of our students who have struggled the
most are from quite affluent backgrounds.
And part of the reason they struggle when
they're in college is because they just don't
have that fire in their belly.
The stakes are not as high.
They're not as driven.
And sometimes, that's a problem.
And so, that's something that we're grappling
with.
So, you'll have a few students who will flunk
out academically.
There's some students who will be expelled
for ethics violations if they do it enough.
There's always a second chance given to people,
depending on the severity of the offense.
But so, we have a few people that fall into
that category.
It's something that we have to do to just
make the point that, "Hey, this is who we
are."
And then, there's a third group that's very
difficult to deal with.
When we give financial aid, and we give a
significant amount of financial aid every
year, but what we do is we commit all the
financial aid dollars we have available upon
entry.
In fact, it's never enough, OK?
And then, after the fact, it may be a couple
of years in, as students' family circumstances
change, they can no longer afford the fees.
There are a few students who drop out because
their families are no longer able to afford
the fees.
And that's very difficult, but it is what
it is.
I mean, we need--.
One of the things that we're trying to do
is to raise extra money, sort of emergency
funding, and the executive team at Ashesi
set up an executive emergency fund that we
contribute to ourselves.
And certain categories of students.
If there's been a death in the family, a parent
has died, or there's some other major incident
like that, they can apply to that fund to
get funding.
But again, even that funding is limited, right?
So, those are the things that cause problems.
[pause]
>>Male Presenter: I think we have time for
one last question.
>>Female #3: I'm last?
OK.
So, you talked about wanting to change a continent.
>>Patrick Awuah: Mm-hmm.
>>Female #3: So, what are your ideas for making
Ashesi scale?
>>Patrick Awuah: The big scale question.
Well, let me say that, first of all, when
I started Ashesi, I had this idea that one
day there would be like, ten Ashesi's in Africa.
And franchise is not the right word because
we're not for profit.
But there would be family of schools around
the continent that have the same mission,
they share the same ethos, that perhaps operate
differently depending in terms of particular
courses they offer, depending on where they
are on the continent.
And I was gonna be the one to make it happen,
OK?
So, then I got started.
And believe me, [laughs] it is really hard.
So, what we, where we are now is to say, "OK.
We've done the first phase of our project,
the first ten years."
Hugely successful in my view.
And we're doing the second phase, which is
about really identifying a few very high-impact
areas that if we do will be transformative
in Ghana--just public, private.
And then to say, "Well, we're going to invite
students from all over the continent to experience
this."
And they'll go back to their countries and
make change.
We have examples of this.
We have someone who went back to Liberia who
is making a big difference.
There's somebody who went back to Sierra Leone
who is making a huge difference.
And just expand it that way.
Now, once we've built the model, then the
question is how do we take that and scale
it.
OK?
And it's dawned on me that the way to take
it and scale it is I need to build up my organization.
We actually need focused minds on how do you
take this and replicate it?
And depending on funding levels and so on,
we may or may not need other Patricks to execute
this.
And I think that the leadership is really
important.
Now, this one has been super difficult because
funding was very scarce when we started.
It required somebody who was absolutely dedicated
and persistent and willing to go through a
bunch of stuff.
Those people are hard to find.
But, and so, those projects need to go through
that same pain.
Then, we will need to find people in those
countries that have that persistence and that
dedication, who are gonna go through the pain
to get it done.
It's gonna be crucial.
And it's hard to find those guys.
Now, if there's funding for it, then it may
be different.
But I haven't figured it all out yet.
But it would be really cool if we could replicate
Ashesi.
So, that's why the second answer is replicating
the idea.
So, there's replicating what we've done and
there is looking at other institutions that
already exist, that already have infrastructure,
that already have people, and say, "Can we,
is there a way that we can inject the Ashesi
DNA, the Ashesi ethos into those institutions?"
And that also is gonna require sitting down
and thinking about exactly how we do that.
But those are the two ways that, I think,
eventually we will look at the scale question.
>>Male Presenter: Thank you, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming, Patrick.
I know there are a lot of--.
Some of you have meetings throughout the afternoon.
If you don't have that time scheduled and
you want to try and find some time, come see
me afterwards.
And I'll thank you again.
>>Patrick Awuah: Thank you very much.
[applause]